non
je
bonjour et bienvenue à strasbourg au
coeur du parlement européen pour cette
nouvelle édition d' europe hebdo quel
est le bon rythme scolaire pour les
petits européens la réforme est en cours
en france
reportage en bavière où l'on fait la
classe le matin comme le veut la
tradition allemande mais d'abord
l'actualité la sphère cahuzac a remis la
question des paradis fiscaux au coeur du
débat européen
alors à quand la fin du secret bancaire
c'est la question de la semaine
on l'avait presque oublié ce dossier
le secret bancaire ce sacro-saint secret
bancaire
il faut dire que ces cachotteries sont
bien gardés au sein de l'union
comment il y à de l'évasion fiscale dans
l'europe quoi il existe des paradis
fiscaux sur le continent vous plaisantez
chypre luxembourg l'autriche les îles de
jersey de guernesey et la suisse depuis
les rebondissements de la sphère cahuzac
les ministres de l'économie de l'union
tente de convaincre ses mauvais élèves
de mettre à disposition les informations
bancaires de leurs clients
la simple si le luxembourg a fait un pas
l'autriche freine toujours mais même les
états unis ont fait plier les banques et
mis en place un système de mesure qui
permet de lutter contre l'exil mais
pourtant en 2009 nicolas sarkozy avait
aboli des paradis fiscaux non alors
c'est pour quand cette fin du secret
bancaire
et nous voilà de retour parlement
européen à strasbourg alors quand la fin
du secret bancaire c'est un petit peu le
serpent de mer dont on entend parler
depuis des années pour en parler yannick
jadot nous a rejoint sur ce plateau
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes député
européen membre du groupe des verts et
surtout vice président de la commission
commerce international alors finalement
on nous l'avait promis avec sarkozy en
2009 promis c'est la fin des paradis
fiscaux du secret bancaire
on nous l'a re joue encore une fois
aujourd'hui avec françois hollande
est ce que vous le croyez cette fois le
président de la république je crois
surtout que les conditions ont changé
c'est vrai que c'est ce sont des
promesses qui sont mis à chaque fois
qu'un scandale on raconte ça aux
citoyens du monde entier est tellement
on ne fait pas grand chose mais là c'est
vrai que les conditions changent et 1
il ya une nécessité économique les états
sont totalement essorer financièrement
donc les états ont besoin de recettes
fiscales et la crise sociale la crise
économique fait que le consentement à
l'impôt est de plus en plus faibles donc
l'évasion fiscale la fraude fiscale sont
beaucoup moins tolérées qu'avant on a
besoin des runways à 25 milliards de
capitaux placés à l'étranger qui
échappent complètement aux états sur la
france on est même jusqu'à 40 50
milliards selon les estimations
et au niveau européen on est à mille
milliards donc c'est considérable la la
la la la perte en recettes fiscales
liées à la fraude fiscale comme à
l'optimisation fiscale
le deuxième élément c'est évidemment
l'élément politique la sphère cahuzac a
fait remonter le populisme en france
comme d'autres à faire dans d'autres
pays européens il ya nécessité
d'apporter des règles et de dire que
finalement même les plus riches doivent
répondre à la règle commune
et puis dernier élément qui est
peut-être finalement le plus important
c'est que les états unis ont fait la
démonstration qu'on peut exiger de
paradis fiscaux là où il ya le secret
bancaire qui est entretenue on peut
exiger les informations pour
l'administration fiscale et à partir du
moment où les états unis sont en train
d'obtenir du luxembourg
de la suisse et d'autres pays européens
ou non européens
les informations fiscales la fin de la
transe de la deûle à l'opacité bancaire
et bien évidemment les pays européens
n'ont plus qu'à s'aligner à suivre le
chemin ouvert par les états unis à dire
au luxembourg à l'autriche ou la suisse
vous faites avec les états unis donc
vous devez le faire avec nous parler de
la loi le fait qu'à qui a été votée aux
états unis effectivement donc ça oblige
en fait les pays étrangers et les
banques à donner les informations
bancaires des ressortissants américains
mais on voit bien qu en europe là il ya
eu un ecofin donc un conseil des
ministres des finances européens que
l'autriche bloc et tout le monde pointe
la city fin l'angleterre avec les îles
de jersey de guernesey finalement
on a déjà des paradis fiscaux dans
l'europe parce qu'on devrait pas
nettoyer notre linge sale en famille
avant d'aller pointer le doigt sur les
étrangers c'est évident c'était donc la
mission première des européens
aujourd'hui c'est balayer devant leur
porte
la france chypre est un paradis fiscal
on sait qu'on a un certain territoire
notamment dans les antilles ou ailleurs
qui servent de paradis fiscaux qui
servent à l'évasion fiscale est
évidemment l'ensemble des pays européens
est concerné mais ce qui a aujourd'hui
c'est que il ya on n'a jamais eu aussi
une hausse ou une fenêtre aussi ouverte
en termes de modification des
réglementations on voit bien qu'au
parlement européen
on entre on a on a voté sur les bonus
des banquiers
on voit de plus en plus sur les échanges
d'informations ce qu'il faut c'est que
le cadre qu'on va poser qui doit porter
la fin des paradis fiscaux
c'est un cadre qui doit aller jusqu'au
bout du processus mais c'est quand on
dit pardon tout ce qu'on avait dit en
2009 avec nicolas sarkozy via le g8/g20
les allées froides on n'avait pas eu
facta on n'avait pas eu la démonstration
qui suffit de volonté politique pour y
arriver et que maintenant l'égalité
traitement d'une certaine façon au
niveau des états fait que la france peut
demander au luxembourg la même chose que
lui demande
les etats-unis qui font s'était en
revanche là où faut vraiment travailler
sérieusement c'est qu'il suffit pas
simplement de savoir quels sont les
comptes d'épargné de personnes physiques
placés dans ces banques
on sait bien que tout le jeu des paradis
fiscaux c'est d'orchestrer des sociétés
écrans des trusts des fondations bien
évidemment où on ne sait plus qui
bénéficient de ces paradis fiscaux
il ya eu un reportage dans un
hebdomadaire français
cette semaine qu'ils monteraient à
combien tapie était devenu maître dans
le montage de sociétés écrans donc on il
faut absolument que cette transparence
se fassent à la fois sur l'ensemble des
produits financiers qui sont placés dans
des comptes à l'étranger
et puis que ça touche pas simplement les
personnes physiques mais évidemment
aussi les personnes morales toutes ces
sociétés écrans
son qui forment le trou noir aujourd'hui
de la finance internationale oui et qui
paye 3 % d'impôt contre 33 1/3 pour les
pme et je n'ai pas les moyens
d'accueillir un élément aussi qui fait
bouger le royaume uni alors le royaume
uni ont cessé spécialisée dans la
finance
il a fait la financiarisation de
l'économie parce qu'ils ont ils ont tué
leur industrie ils ont tué leur
agriculture
donc ils ont toujours eu besoin de faire
du dumping fiscal pour attirer les
sociétés chez eux mais en même temps ils
s'aperçoivent que des grandes des grands
groupes multinationaux qui sont placés à
londres ne paient quasiment pas d'impôt
chez eux donc au finish le fait
d'attirer des sociétés ne se traduit pas
forcément par des recettes fiscales
supplémentaires puisque comme vous le
dites
en france les grands groupes
multinationaux notamment ceux du cac 40
payent à peu près lui % d'impôts alors
que les petites et moyennes entreprises
c'est plutôt 30 33 et en grande bretagne
c'est encore moi et ça c'est j'allais
dire le deuxième grand chantier à côté
de celui des paradis fiscaux c'est tout
l'évasion fiscale légale
tous ces deux par dieu toutes ces
sociétés anonymes ces sociétés privées
qui quitte un territoire pour aller sur
un autre territoire européen
parce qu'il ya du dumping fiscal m'en
voulais faire revenir à ce qu'il faut
voter aujourd'hui une amnistie pour
faire revenir ces capitaux parce
qu'après tout ils se sont cachés ils
disent on va prendre 60% d'imposition
sur le conte aura rapatriés est-ce qu'il
faut voter aujourd'hui une amnistie
fiscale pour permettre de rapatrier ses
capitaux je crois pas l'amnestie fiscale
je crois qu'aujourd'hui le fait que
l'europe mais pas de politique fiscale
commune fait que ceux qui peuvent bouger
les acteurs les plus mobiles que ce soit
les grandes sociétés ou les plus hauts
revenus mais il se hisse s'expatrie en
belgique et s'expatrie en irlande en
grande-bretagne aux pays-bas ou ailleurs
donc je pense pas qu'ils aient
aujourd'hui une telle citoyenneté ou un
tel sentiment de citoyenneté qui vont
dire voilà j'ai pas bien fait j'ai fait
voilà on a tous à part dont ma faute
morale
j'irais là confère une confession à
l'impérial à jeffrey une confession à la
télé et tout ira bien non ce qu'il faut
et ça c'est la responsabilité des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement européens
c'est d'avoir d'aller vers
l'harmonisation fiscale européenne pour
éviter ce dumping cette course au moins
disant fiscal qui tue nos dépenses en
matière d'école en matière de santé en
matière d'investissement et c'est pour
ça que nous nous proposons les
écologistes un taux harmonisé minimum de
25% sur les sociétés après aux
différents états d'en rajouter s'ils
veulent mais au moins 25% comme ça on
arrête cette course à l'échalote entre
ou sur l'album pink fiscale qui tue nos
démocraties aujourd'hui un autre dossier
donc qu'on suivra bien entendu merci
beaucoup et yannick jadot d'avoir été
parmi nous vous l'avez dit le grand
dossier qui nous a occupés ces derniers
temps c'est cahuzac et notamment la
question de la transparence puisque la
plupart des ministres enfin les
ministres français en fait avant
peut-être les députés ont déclaré leur
patrimoine
et cela bien entendu a fait causer nos
voisins européens un petit tour des
télévisions étrangères c'est avec
aurélie la face transparence et
moralisation deux maîtres mots pour un
grand déballage au gouvernement le
patrimoine des ministres français c'est
là une des télévisions européennes
mélissa président jean marc ayrault
affiche un million et demi de patrimoine
autres riches du gouvernement michèle
delaunay la ministre déléguée aux
personnes âgées avec 5 millions quatre
cent mille euros et marisol touraine aux
ministres aux affaires sociales
avec un million quatre cent mille euros
étaient les plus pauvres sur la ministre
de l'environnement cécile duflot avec
une maison dans les landes une twingo et
une 4l puis la ministre de la culture
aurélie filippetti avec un appartement
de 60 m² à paris
un étalage de richesse vient obligé pour
redresser la côte de françois hollande
selon ce journaliste britannique le
modèle de modestie prôné par françois
hollande avant l'élection présidentielle
cette idée d'une société plus juste
a été mise à mal par les mensonges et
les excès de son ministre du budget la
cote de popularité du président était
déjà basses elle est désormais
catastrophique
en belgique les élus d'être là et
j'adore 7 à 13 ans mais il ne le rendent
pas que ouverte alors scandale français
amène les médias à poser la question
faut-il aller plus loin imposer à tout
le monde de rendre cela public pourquoi
à moins de le faire alors pour
l'ensemble des citoyens
les joueurs de football les artistes
tous les citoyens alors
mais là vous avez l'administration
fiscale le contrôle des revenus
il y a dans cette lettre qui est déposée
auprès de la cour des comptes
des éléments qui ont trait à la vie
privée et c'est justement un journaliste
belge qui nous a rejoint pour évoquer
cette question de la transparence en
france maroun labaki bonjour vous êtes
donc journaliste au soir un quotidien de
référence en belgique
est-ce que comment est ce que vous voyez
en fait ce grand débat qu'on a en france
sur cette question de la transparence
est ce que pour vous c'est une
démocratie paparazzi on va écouter nous
on voit ça surtout je crois qu'on voit
les choses pour ce qu'elles sont c'est à
dire françois hollande
était en très mauvaise posture politique
il devrait trouver quelque chose dans la
précipitation et voilà donc c'est une
opération de com et leur vocation ceux
là où il n'y a pas de noms je crois
qu'il faut poser la question de la
transparence c'est évidemment légitime
mais ça s'est fait quand même dans une
extraordinaire précipitation donc je
veux dire on peut pas dire qu'on a
beaucoup réfléchi sur les conséquences
applications donc on fait quelque chose
qui est de nature à calmer un peu
l'opinion publique voilà alors après on
peut débattre évidemment du bien fondé
de jusqu'où on va etc
mais au fond c'est une opération de
communication politique et ça nous
intéresse beaucoup parce que en belgique
nous suivons de très près la politique
française alors justement belgique
comment ça se passe vous aussi vos élus
déclarent en fait leur patrimoine
oui il déclaré tandis que ce qui est
public ce sont tous les mandats dont ils
disposent donc rémunérés ou pas ça doit
être mis à jour tous les ans et c'est
public et donc tous les tous les élus à
tous les niveaux sont tenus de le faire
donc c'est leur salaire qui est déclaré
finalement oui il ya une rémunération
dans les conseils d'administration dans
les intercommunales enfin dans toutes
sortes de structures dans mais leur
patrimoine n'est pas rendu public
alors non le patrimoine est déclarée
mais ça se fait sous scellés et donc
ceux déposés à la cour des comptes en
cas de problème si un juge d'instruction
veut à y avoir accès il va regarder
et puis voilà cela dit ça s'est jamais
passé
donc vous avez une classe politique
exemplaire bon en tout cas en tout cas
ceux qui ceux qui trichent le font bien
mais disons aussi il faut réfléchir à
cet aspect des choses c'est à dire on
n'a pas demandé la transparence et
publié ce 6 publié cela celui qui triche
et qui a une société offshore il va pas
mettre dans cette île dans un petite
enveloppe scellée j'ai une chose était
sûre un logo là effectivement c'est du
déclaratif donc si vous voulez continue
de cacher que vous avez un compte en
suisse ou à singapour
rien
voilà mais est-ce qu'on doit aller vers
plus de transparence certains en france
disent que c'est une démocratie
paparazzi cas une forme de voyeurisme on
voit pourtant que chez nos voisins
d'europe du nord en suède en finlande ça
pose absolument pas de problème est-ce
que vous allez on doit tendre vers ça
écoutez moi
a priori je dirais que la vie privée
c'est quelque chose de sacré et ça vaut
pour vous pour moi pour tout un chacun
et aussi pour le personnel politique
donc c'est une première chose donc je
crois qu'il faut manier tout ça avec une
extrême prudence
ensuite je n'aime pas beaucoup qu'on
stigmatise la classe politique
or dans cette démarche il ya qu'il y a
quelque chose d'un peu malsain et puis
j'aime pas beaucoup même si je n'en fais
pas partie
malheureusement qu'on stigmatise les
riches je trouve que c'est idiot
enfin parce que voilà vous avez bien vu
comment tout le monde a réagi en
regardant la liste des ministres tout le
temps a été regardée sur les plus riches
à leur poids comment ça se fait que
enfin je dis je trouve que évidemment
que le personnel politique doit être
irréprochable mais on doit faire
attention à ne pas trop les populismes
voilà voilà parce que parce que c'est ça
au fond merci maroun labaki d'avoir
analysé pour nous ce qui se passe chez
vos voisins français nous on continue
notre petit tour d'europe
vous savez qu'en france en ce moment
nous mettons en place une réforme des
rythmes scolaires pour passer à quatre
jours et demi et notre modèle
semble-t-il c'est le modèle allemand
alors nous avons été en bavière pour
essayer de voir comment l'école
allemande fonctionne c'est un reportage
de mélanie bon temps et de paul bouffard
très tôt le matin c'est un ballet
d'écoliers qui s'activent en bavière
comme dans le reste du pays début de
journée à 7h40 pour les petits allemands
michael kraus est instituteur dans le
village de castle ici comme le veut la
tradition allemande
la classe est donné le matin ils
débutent leur journée avec des petits
jeux d'informatique
alors ici on commence le matin comment
ce matin à 7h40 les cours durent environ
45 minutes
il y a deux pauses une première de 20
minutes à 9h10 puis une seconde un peu
plus tard les cours finissent
normalement aux alentours de 12h40
c'est ce système qui est aujourd'hui la
source d'inspiration du gouvernement
français dans sa réforme des rythmes
scolaires en allemagne
les élèves ont en moyenne 193 jours
d'école par an contre 140 en france
moins de vacances mais un rythme plus ou
avec moins d'heures de classe seulement
cinq par jour
au final c'est moins de fatigue pour les
écoliers ouais je pense que bien sûr
quand on doit rester à l'école jusqu'à
midi et qu'ensuite on retourne dans son
environnement familial on est peut-être
moins fatiguer le si l'on reste à
l'école jusqu'à 16 heures à l'école on
ne peut jamais vraiment se décontracter
à castle et dans la plupart des écoles
d'allemagne on compte en moyenne 21
élèves par classe loukas 9 ans et en
dernière année de primaire
d'abord en allemand ensuite pour demain
mois après l'école je rentre à la maison
aujourd'hui j'ai match de foot
l'après-midi le faire être dehors et
jouer avec mes amis
autre classe ici ses cours d'orthographe
avec red hat strauss institutrice depuis
17 ans à cas cela en tant que professeur
l'après midi je peux travailler corriger
et préparer mes cours pour les prochains
jours
à 13 heures les jeunes allemands field à
la garderie d'autres vont en cours de
musique ou encore aux sports autre
différence de taille avec la france le
salaire des professeurs ici à munich en
bavière un jeune instituteur commence
avec 2200 euros net par mois
1600 pour un français système éducatif
financé par les länder régions pour les
titres qui ont le statut anticipation à
l'échelon national pour une réforme et
martelé le ministre
comme tous les matins axel drainage
prépare les enfants
une nouvelle journée d'école pour shirin
et noam le papa est français il vit en
allemagne depuis 15 ans ces enfants sont
nés et scolarisés ici à munich alors il
peut comparer ça leur laisse beaucoup de
temps beaucoup plus de temps pour faire
leurs devoirs ou pour ou pour simplement
aller à la bibliothèque ou pour pour
pour en fait pour avoir la possibilité
d'apprendre par d'autres moyens
simplement que dans l'école la question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait des enfants
l'après-midi effectivement quand les
enfants n'ont pas d'école il faut les
occuper comme on travaille tous les deux
avec ma femme on arrive assez on a
réussi on a eu de la chance mais a
réussi à avoir une place pour les deux
mais il ya beaucoup de gens
effectivement qu'ils sont obligés
finalement de travailler en mi temps ou
de ne pas travailler de ne pas
travailler pour pouvoir s'occuper de
leurs enfants d'après midi en allemagne
la tradition est tenace et
particulièrement dans les länder de
l'ancienne allemagne de l'est où la
maman reste à la maison pour élever ses
enfants dans plus de 50 % des couples
avec un enfant de moins de 6 ans seul
l'homme travaille donc pas facile de
gérer un emploi du temps avec ce rythme
scolaire vient justement beaucoup de nos
gens qui demandent des places en
garderie et qui repart pour l'instant
y'a pas les infrastructures pour cent un
modèle jalousé par toute l'europe qui se
remet aujourd'hui en question le système
s'essouffle devant les inégalités
sociales du coup pourquoi pas une école
à temps plein c'est nécessaire pour deux
raisons tout d'abord c'est une
possibilité pédagogique
on dispose de plus en plus de temps pour
l'enseignement d'un autre côté il ya
tout simplement la réalité sociale mais
plus en plus de familles ont besoin de
cette possibilité de laisser leurs
enfants à l'école
toute la journée le nombre de femmes
actives aux demandes de plus en plus et
je pense que c'est une question d'emploi
du temps la journée complète à l'école
est une conséquence du développement du
travail des femmes
aujourd'hui les pédagogues allemands
restent satisfaits mais pour continuer à
garantir à la fois une bonne éducation
et l'emploi des femmes
l'allemagne doit remettre en cause ses
vieilles traditions depuis 2004 plus de
4 milliards d'euros ont été investis
pour permettre à un tiers des écoles
primaires d'offrir une journée de classe
à temps plein
c'était un portage de paul bouffard
tourné dans une école de bavière nous
sommes toujours au coeur du parlement
européen à strasbourg est notre invité
nous a rejoint jean marie cavada bonjour
merci d'être là vous êtes député
européen ancien président de radio
france et vous est notamment membre de
la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation du parlement européen
à voir ce reportage on a l'impression
que tout va plutôt bien notamment dans
la petite ville allemande de castres le
la classe le matin comme la pratique
l'allemagne est ce que pour vous c'est
le modèle à suivre en europe
en tout cas c'est l'orientation qu'il
faut prendre il ya plusieurs choses
d'ailleurs qu'il faut dire tout ce qui
peut concourir à alléger une journée
mais a allongé le nombre de journées
d'école est une bonne chose
la france était avant la réforme peillon
dans une moyenne de cent quarante quatre
jours après la réforme je crois que ce
sera à peu près 180 180 c'est une
moyenne européenne
setc ces 10 jours de moins que la
finlande et c'est 30 jours de moins que
le pays où il ya le plus d'écoles dans
une année qui elle danemark mais en gros
180 jours c'est une bonne moyenne ce qui
permet quoi de mieux étaler les cours de
faire en sorte que les enfants ne soient
pas abrutis de fatigue et puis ensuite
perdu dans des vacances interminable
parce qu'il faudra bien s'attaquer au
deuxième volet qui est la durée des
vacances
je crois comprendre que c'est dans la
tête de vincent peillon je pense que
dans ce domaine là il n'a pas que des
amis mais l'intérêt général passe par
dessus au dessus de l'intérêt du
tourisme et puis dans cet état jacobin
faut apprendre à faire ce que
l'allemagne fait c'est-à-dire
désarticulé en autorités régionales la
prise de décision des vacances par
exemple l'éducation nationale ça veut
pas dire que tout le monde est en
vacances partout en même temps c'est à
dire pas le cas en france sauf l'été est
ce que c'est que ces vacances est une
spécificité française parce que quand on
regarde les chiffres 12 semaines de
vacances en espagne en italie six
semaines seulement pour les écoliers aux
pays bas en allemagne et ce qu'on
travaille plus au nord aussi il est bien
évidemment oui oui bien sûr on travaille
il ya une relation l'espagne l'italie et
la france sont des pays des gens
peu gorgés de soleil alors le tourisme a
pris le pas et on a élargi petit à petit
va quand je ne voudrais pas à faire un
rappel mais quand j'étais enfant les
vacances c'était après le 14 juillet et
l'école reprenait fin août ou au maximum
début septembre
donc c'était un mois et demi c'était
déjà très bien franchement et donc il ya
il ya un deuxième point c'est les
vacances d'été et un troisième point
qu'il faudra un jour atteindre
sérieusement c'est celui je dirais de
l'equilibre d'une journée aller
davantage vers ce que font les allemands
c'est à dire davantage de sport de
loisirs de divertissements de travaux
pratiques et d'accompagnement les gosses
ils ont besoin d'avoir un bon
enseignement et ils ont besoin d'avoir
aussi de quoi s'épanouir de la liberté
du sport pour soutenir l'attention des
très jeunes
il faut alterner les activités sur une
journée il faut pas avoir oui
naturellement à tout moment avec tous
les peuples savent ça c'est que il on
peut pas donner huit heures de courant
continu à des bébés à des petits enfants
ça ne tient pas debout 1 et il ya une
dernière chose que je voudrais dire une
bonne réforme devrait aller jusqu'au
bout des choses c'est à dire améliorer
le salaire des enseignants de base il
faut le dire vous avez vu dans votre
reportage l'allemagne à s'il ya quand
même 600 euros de différence pour un
instituteur à équivalence mais bien
entendu que c'est important
bien entendu on évite la paupérisation
d'un métier puis ce sont des métiers
contrairement à ce qui se dit bien sûr
il ya beaucoup de vacances mais aussi
dans une journée
c'est dur il ya beaucoup de fatigue et
puis quand vous rentrez chez vous vous
avez aussi vos enfants ça n'a pas été
bien pensé tout ça et puis petit à petit
on a calomnié l'éducation comme une
sorte de périmètre de privilégier tout
ça est absolument absurde
il faut que le gouvernement et l'inter
et le sens de l'intérêt général et
brille cette affaire des vacances cette
affaire des salaires progressivement
parce que je sais bien que les finances
publiques n'ont pas les moyens d'être
très prodigue en matière de financement
alors on dit que l'allemagne est souvent
cité en exemple en même temps la classe
le matin est un peu remis en cause
puisque se développe en allemagne des
activités l'après midi est ce qu'il faut
en raison notamment du
de l'adaptation nécessaire au travail
des femmes est ce qu'il faut adapter les
rythmes scolaires à l'évolution de la
réalité sociale et notamment travail des
femmes j'ai tendance à dire que le
travail des femmes pose un problème
comme autrefois le travail des enfants
dans les fermes des agriculteurs dans
avant les années 60 où les fermes qui
avait pas d'argent avait besoin de bras
c'était les enfants moi même d'ailleurs
quand j'étais tout gamin élevé dans une
ferme des vosges
j'ai participé aux travaux de la ferme
et je pense qu'il faut quand même dans
la république de jules ferry dire une
chose très claire
l'éducation des enfants l'instruction
est l'éducation des enfants passent
avant toute autre considération sociale
ou économique
il faut dire c'est un jour l'intérêt de
l'enfant d'abord l'intérêt que
l'inspiration c'est après on verra le
reste est pour vous l'école de jules
ferry a vécu aujourd'hui ou quelle est
sa première mission finalement on va
faire en sorte nos soins n'a pas vécu
mais il faudra pratiquement rappeler les
principes il ya des il ya des familles
où les enfants ne vont pas à l'école
il ya des familles où les enfants vont à
l'école mais traverse la sorte en très
mauvais état
savent à peine lire savent à peine
compte et enfin bref et donc la mission
de l'école de jules ferry à nouveau
beaucoup de sens et il faut s'armer pour
qu'elle soit efficace auprès de ses
enfants déclassé socialement qui ne
n'auront jamais le destin social
intéressant et qui pour une partie
d'entre eux d'ailleurs on le voit bien
fondé délinquants par conséquent c'est
vraiment redevenu très important très
très importants et le modèle éducatif
européen il va plutôt bien
le modèle éducatif européen ne se porte
pas mal oui franchement franchement
en même temps quand on rentre dans les
couches supérieures c'est à dire je
pense notamment à l'enseignement
supérieur
ce modèle de tendre à se rapprocher de
la réalité de la société c'est-à-dire de
l'économie de l'emploi ou aussi de
savoir garder ses chercheurs à ces
jeunes ce qui me frappe beaucoup c'est
que beaucoup de jeunes quittent l'europe
pour aller au mieux ils restent en
europe en grande bretagne mais pour
aller surtout dans d'autres continents
parce qu'ils trouvent que l'europe a
beaucoup vieilli il faut que l'europe se
reprenne en main y compris dans le
système éducatif développer
l'apprentissage faut développer
l'apprentissage en parallèle avec le
même degré de grades de gradation que
les études intellectuelle entre
guillemets bien entendu c'est très
important ça est ce que pour vous
actuellement le système français est
inégalitaire
je n'aime pas faire des chapelles s'il
est théorisé mais vous savez dans
l'éducation il est toujours plus facile
pour les familles aisées de soutenir les
efforts des enfants que pour les
familles ça c'est une réalité que c'est
une réalité
alors moi j'ai vécu dans un système
n'ayant pas de famille du tout où la
bourse d'état a joué le rôle du soutien
économique familiale
je ne sais pas si c'est encore il y en a
beaucoup en cours de bourse un je ne
sais pas si c'est toujours aussi
efficace parce qu'une bourse n'est pas
suffisant il faut un éducateur référent
qui vous soutient une faute une personne
un professeur x un instituteur et ça je
ne sais pas dans quelle mesure ça
fonctionne je me méfie quand même des
schémas généraux et bien merci jean
marie cavada d'avoir été l'invité sur
vous d'inventer le dos vous laisse
retourner dans l'hémicycle où je vais
recruter un ou vous allez voter c'est
bien et nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine à bruxelles avec françois vos
données pour une autre émission d'europe
et d'autres est bonne ce type de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires